earlier we looked at clips of interviews
that Luke Beasley did with Trump
supporters at his rally in Pickens South
Carolina over the holiday weekend let's
now look at clips of the actual rally
one of the most interesting things was
that Republican South Carolina Senator
Lindsey Graham was brutally brutally
booed he had a speech himself and he was
booed and ran off stage and then when
Trump talked about him he was also booed
here is Lindsay cutting it short
after getting heckled the entire time
and running off of the stage you you
really you love to see it you really do
God Bless America
[Music]
a visibly frustrated Lindsey Graham
brutally booed by a supposedly friendly
Maga crowd and walks off stage when
Trump mentioned Lindsay the crowd also
not convinced twice not you know you can
make mistakes on occasion
even Lindsay down here Senator Lindsey
Graham We Love Saturday we're good act
we're gonna love him
I know it's half and half but what I
need some of those liberal votes he's
always there to help me get them okay
we got some pretty liberal people but
he's good he's good we know the good
ones we know the bad ones crowd is very
very very very much not convinced Trump
then going into woke going into elements
of woke and says nobody knows what
wokeness is
for women and you know the amazing thing
because of our crazy woke society and I
hate the word woke actually because
nobody even has a real accurate
description it means lack of Common
Sense more than anything else but
because of
sorry sir woke means you are aware of
injustices in society and you'd like to
fix them at least if it's possible Trump
as news was breaking about his phone
call to pressure Arizona's Governor to
overturn the 2020 election results
weighed in during his speech about his
phone call to try to get Georgia
officials to overturn the election
results and he continues to exist
insists rather this was just a perfect
call copy of it it was a perfect call
these were perfect calls these were
calls where you're questioning the
validity
and the safety of Elections and it's a
disgrace that they're allowed to even
think about it but not one person
protested until long after that call
right and if there was something wrong
with that call I am not a stupid person
number one I'm an honest person so I
wouldn't do it anyway but when people
are on the opponent Trump would know
whether there was anything right or
wrong whether there was anything wrong
with the call that's not true Trump
doesn't know anything and Trump would
never lie about the call that's not true
Trump lies all the time I think many
lawyers do you think many people were on
that phone
many many people do you think I'm going
to say what they'd like to have but the
problem is
it's not borne out I will tell you what
is born out the call was supposedly
taped in the State of Florida and on
Florida you're not allowed to do you
know that's a two-party state in other
words you're not allowed to take phone
calls they taped the phone call to show
you how nice they are they take the
phone call all right so Trump rambling
and rambling about that none of us
believe it and then lastly Donald Trump
directly attacking special prosecutor
Jack Smith it's hard to believe this is
a good strategy for the presidential
records act well that's what they should
be looking at because everything I did
was under the presidential records act
we have a thug prosecutor
named Smith Jack Smith he's a thug he's
had many losses he's destroyed many
lives and they put him in charge in the
meantime what about Biden's records this
guy has 1850 boxes he has boxes stored
in Chinatown in DC rough place by the
way and Trump continuing to tell the
same debunked lies about Joe Biden and
his documents it's the greatest hits but
I have to tell you even the cult crowd
seems a little bit skeptical but not the
cultists were about to look at video of
one of our sponsors is yada the Free
banking app that makes it fun to save
money just like a regular bank account
you can withdraw your money anytime and
it's fully FDIC insured when you keep
your money in a yada bank account you'll
have a shot at winning nightly cash
prizes ranging from two cents to a
million dollars for every twenty five
dollars in your account you get one
recurring ticket to the nightly prize
drawing so if you deposit a hundred
dollars you get four tickets every
single night without needing to make any
more deposits yada also offers some
great budgeting features the possibility
of early paydays a debit card that
rewards you with up to one hundred
percent cash back and tickets on every
purchase yada members have already won
over 15 million dollars so say goodbye
to the traditional savings account with
the minimal interest rate Freakonomics
have described prize linked savings
accounts like a no lose Lottery download
the app now start saving for a chance to
win big with yada the app where savings
meets excitement go to with yada.com
Pacman the link is in the description